pourquoi 21 écrit et ce fut dans le game
et et c'est que mme alliot sur la
toujours le favori le préférer le numéro
un
mais bon au fond de mannequin ça ne me
dérange pas bon je ne suis plus gentil
le tuteur légal pendant son sommeil
chevelure faire la moue stage
on verra bientôt qui sera le champion
quand juppé à avaler c'est 200
champignons mon quart des preuves il
tombe toujours en panne je veux pas
tourner je me prends pour les postale
munich et salace je veux qu'une carapace
moi j'peux concas le mode kamikazes
on peut les coûts que mario soit le m
alors tu ce mec tu me plusieurs mandats
m cette petite clope et s'habille en
salopette alors que moi ah ouais moi
aussi en fait
jonathan de mario
j'ai dit mon s'est lui dit tu décris
et là tant de marivaux est vrai je suis
vénère jetant habillés en vert avec
cette couleur on prend pour un éboueur
mario par l'ats mario parent si le père
ce qu'ont choisi ce n'est jamais luigi
part quand je fais des efforts bruit qui
fait du sport cher à max de pecs lui est
gros comme un pas qu'on m'accuse mansion
c'était ma carrière solo mais en un peu
tu meurs ils ont mis un aspirateur
regarde on veut aussi
et ledit j'écris
gilles
on s'est lui dit de marivaux je n'ai pas
la peste
je ne suis pas boiteux alors pourquoi
luigi est toujours le joueur de [ __ ]
samsung mario fait des coups francs
manquaient luigi et des rigoles en tout
petit sa meuf chapelle pitch c'est le
nom d'une brioche fripons un code qui
sera méga moche mais tu vois du talon je
tenais pas si sûr toutes ses cascades
sont faites par une coupure tellement
mario psq la salle figurines thèse qu'il
prend le mot l'on traîne avec alain 2
ger d'ego prends des cachets illégaux
mais le meilleur épisode c'est quand
j'avais peixoto non non on faisait pas
j'ai bien fait pitié tu veux venir
non merci et le 10g
massuyès m'était familière
mario est locataire luigi est
propriétaire jusqu'au prier terre budget
des propriétaires
je suis surpris que des propriétaires
propriétaire qui était propriétaire
maría toi ma chaîne youtube fais-toi
plaisent c'est toi qui clique
oui je fais le 110 mètres de 110 m haies
lourd
[Musique]